and so this guy has a fake phd he writes
for a couple hack outlets
he's uh the founding director of some
fake
academic center at boston university and
he milks people out of money as a
diversity consultant he's an enti he's a
scam artist
and then he has the gall to attack this
woman's family he says
some white colonizers adopted black
children
they civilized these savage children in
the superior ways of white people
while using them as props and their
lifelong pictures of denial while
cutting the biological parents of these
children
out of the picture of humanity
adopting poor kids orphans
from from bad areas
is now a bad thing now of course it's
not and what he's saying by the way is
white people shouldn't adopt black
people right that's that's what's lying
at the bottom of what he's saying
and he's the professor of anti-racism
makes you think huh
maybe this anti-racism thing isn't
really what it what it sounds like
maybe this anti-fascism thing isn't
really really what it sounds like
this is i mean there's no reason to ever
listen to this guy he's a
total fraud and what he says is worth
less than nothing
but the reason i point it out is because
it's a very bad look for democrats
he's saying what a lot of them are
thinking but a lot of
professional democrats you know elected
people operatives
they realize this is going to be a bad
line of attack i don't think it's going
to play in peoria
people are not going to like it when you
attack this woman's children
and attack this woman for adopting
children from
a bad place you know in a bad situation
and giving them a loving home and
raising them and bringing them to the
land of the free
if you attack a woman for that uh not
going to be a good look in november
so this brings us then to the fourth
attack first two they can't lob the
third one they do love but it looks
really bad
the fourth one is attacking her religion
you know dianne feinstein already did
this said that the dogma
lives loudly within amy coney barrett
because she's a catholic
same thing dick durbin said the city
goes what you actually believe
catholicism you're orthodox and you're
in your religion that's so weird what
i've never heard of that before
and then bill maher put it in less
polite terms
but apparently the pick is going to be
this umi umi
amy comey will all be saying this name a
lot i'm sure because she's a
nut religion
i was right about that one too amy
sorry but amy
comey barrett catholic really catholic i
mean
really really catholic like speaking in
tongues
like she doesn't believe in condoms
which is what she has in common with
trump because he doesn't either
[Applause]
also a terrible look for democrats first
of all
when bill maher speaks doesn't he just
remind you of that
like smug 13 year old you knew in middle
school
who who whose arguments for atheism were
more or less
um i can't see god where is he i can't
touch him
checkmate theists yeah um
if god is real then uh
why why won't he manifest himself
physically when i demand it
um checkmate christians it's just
so shallow it's as if
as if people hadn't been thinking of
these questions before as if
saint thomas aquinas never existed as if
the summa theologia didn't exist as if
saint augustine didn't exist
as if the great geniuses of history the
great doctors of the church
because then bill maher comes and says
wait a second
i can't see god or whatever his dumb
arguments are
you say oh my okay well you're right
there goes my summa theologia time to
set it on fire
even think about pope benedict xvi pope
emeritus benedict xvi
maybe the greatest living theologian a
brilliant scholar who has been writing
and thinking about god
for his entire life who do you think
has a better handle on these things who
do you think has more brain cells
rubbing together who do you think has
spent
more time in serious contemplation of
this question pope benedict
or bill maher i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts